what are the uh
interesting trajectories you see for the
proliferation of virtual reality or
mixed reality yeah so i was um
i was in magic league for
what
five years um with the best title of all
time oh
thanks chief chief futurist yeah yeah
and so i
sort of had a little squad of people in
seattle doing
what you might call content r d so we're
trying to make content for ar
but um
because it's such a new medium
there's it's more of an engineering r d
project almost than a than a creative
project so it was fascinating to see um
everything that goes into
making uh
an ar
system
that runs um so ar
um an ar device if it's really going to
do ar
needs to be running
slam in real time
and that alone is a big so for people
who don't know first of all virtual
reality
is
creating almost fully artificial world
and putting you inside it augmented
reality ar
is taking the real world and putting top
on top
putting stuff on top of that
real world and when you say slam that
means in real time the device needs to
be able to
sense
accurately detect everything about that
world sufficiently
to be able to reconstruct the the 3d
structure of it so you can put stuff on
top of it and doing that in real time
presumably not just real time but in a
way that's creates a pleasant experience
for the human perception system
is uh
yeah that's a that's an engineering
project
right yeah will said and it's just one
of the things that
the system has to do it's also tracking
your eyes
so it knows what you're looking at
how far away
what you're looking at is
it's
it's performing all those functions um
and it's gotta
keep doing that without you know
burning up the
the cpu or or or uh depleting the
battery uh
unreasonably fast and that's that's just
table stakes it's just the basic
functions of the the operating system
and then any content that you want to
add has to sit on top of that
it's got to be rendered by the optics
at a sufficiently low latency that
it looks real and you don't get sick so
it's an amazing thing and um you know
magically shipped a device that
can do that in 2019
and they're about to ship the ml2
but i don't know any more about that
than anyone else because i don't work
there anymore
um
does it still in to some degree boil
down to
a killer app
a content question like you said it's
kind of a wide open space nobody knows
exactly what's going to be the
compelling thing yeah
so doesn't a super compelling experience
of some sort
alleviate some of the
need for engineering perfection
well there's a base layer of engineering
that you have to have no matter what
but you're certainly right that people
like in the early days of video games
put up with
kind of low frame rate and and what we
would now call crappy graphics because
they were having so much fun playing
doom or whatever even tetris yeah yeah
so um
so for sure that's true and so um
you know
i was uh
working on consumer facing content um
there was a great team in
wellington new zealand that made a game
uh called dr groybrot's invaders that
that
realized the the potential of ar gaming
in a way that i don't think anything
else has
before or since
and
so that was definitely the strategy
until uh
what april
2020 which is when
the company decided to
pivot to commercial industrial
applications instead
so um
and
you know i
i haven't seen their their
their financial projections but i assume
they had good reasons for
for making that strategic
decision
it just means that it's no longer
necessarily targeted at
at just end users who want to play a
game or or be entertained but it's
you know that to me from a sort of a
dreamer futurist perspective is
heartbreaking because i i i don't know
necessarily from
in the vr space but i see this kind of
thing
with uh with robotics
where
to me
the future of robotics is consumer
facing
and a lot of great roboticists boston
dynamics and
companies like that are focused on
sort of industrial applications yeah
because for financial business reasons
yeah now i i can see the parallels for
sure you know we'll see it was a fun uh
project you know we uh
uh
we worked on
an app for example called baby goats
which just populated your room with
with baby goats that seems like a killer
app right there well see we we thought
highly of the of the idea for sure yes
um so but because of the slam
uh the
the um
the system knew for example here's a
table here's a little end table
we know the heights
we know how high our animated baby goat
can jump
um
and so
so our engineers had to to build a
system for converting the slam
primitives into um
game engine objects um that that the uh
the
game
the ais in the game could navigate
around
so and that ended up shipping as more of
a dev kit or a sort of how-to a sample
app
than as a
a finished
consumer-facing
you mean the baby goat ai
yeah yeah
i that seems to me like a world
i couldn't entertain myself for hours
just every day coming home to to to to
see if baby goes yeah i mean it was an
ambient
kind of it's not it's not a thing that
you would sit there and play like a a
video just life yeah yeah but now this
baby goes you i mean what's the purpose
of having dogs and cats right in your
life exactly it's kind of ambient yeah
they're not really helping you do
anything but it's enriching your life
and you can go and play fetch or
something for a while if you want but
you don't have to right yeah
so uh
so we worked on that and a bigger
project that was more of a storytelling
in a fictional
uh universe um the hardware is worth a
look there's still a belief i just saw
it this morning looking at twitter that
the magic leap never shipped anything
but they've been
since 2019 you can
go to their website and buy one of these
devices anytime you
want to spend the money yeah and the new
one is coming out i think in 2022 so in
in in a few months
you